[Music]
Lisa Marie Presley rushed to the
hospital after suffering Cardiac Arrest
at home TMZ broke the news EMTs
performed CPR on the star and according
to the outlet administered treatment to
help Presley regain a pulse for now her
rep has no comment on the scary incident
less than 48 hours ago Lisa was at the
Golden Globes celebrating Austin
Butler's performance as her dad Elvis on
the big screen what was it like watching
Austin on stage and during this movie in
the making of this movie it was
mind-blowing truly mind-blowing I really
didn't know what what to do with myself
after after I saw it yeah I had to take
like five days to process it
because it was so incredible and so spot
on
and so authentic
that yeah I I can't even describe
what it meant we just celebrated your
dad's birthday a couple days ago so what
does it mean to you to be here tonight
you know in just a couple days after his
birthday celebrating him again in a way
that the masses are saying we see you
you know I'm just so proud of it all
um
you know it's all flowing really nicely
together I'm gonna have the birthday
right now and you know I'm here to
support Austin and baz and film and I'm
so excited and I hope he wins
you know she deserves it we don't have
to eat any shoes
not yet we're waiting for that one yeah
we'll see
[Music]